so here's the brain of a
non-procrastinator here's my brain both
brains have a rational decision maker in
them but the procrastinator's brain also
has an instant gratification monkey so
the rational decision maker will make
the rational decision to do something
productive but the monkey doesn't like
that plan so he actually takes the wheel
and he says we're not going to really
have room on the schedule for any work
today sorry the instant gratification
monkey does not seem like a guy you want
behind the wheel he only cares about two
things easy and fun sometimes it makes
sense to be doing things that are easy
and fun but other times it makes much
more sense to be doing things that are
harder and Less Pleasant for the sake of
the big picture and that's when we have
a conflict we need to stay aware of the
instant gratification monkey we need to
think about what we're really
procrastinating on because everyone is
procrastinating on something in life
that's a job that should probably start
today well
Maybe not today